the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agree to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones in a
song of ice and fire video
in this video i want to discuss one of
my theories for the upcoming book the
winds of winter
as i'm sure you all know by now we have
been waiting for the release of this
book for nearly a decade
this is easily one of the most highly
anticipated books ever written
now there are a number of different
reasons why i'm anxiously awaiting for
the winds of winter but what has me very
excited is knowing this is when we will
most likely see
the invasion of the white walkers as of
right now the wall is still standing in
the books
the wall is still there and the white
walkers have yet to invade westeros
but all of that is about to change in
the winds of winter
obviously when the white walkers invade
the seven kingdoms
all of our favorite characters will have
to find a way to stop them from
advancing any further
we all saw how this was done in the show
but i don't think that's how it will be
done in the book
so in this video i want to discuss how i
think the white walkers will
ultimately be stopped there are so many
different ways this can happen
but based on some of the evidence i have
found i think i know how this will be
done
some of you might have even heard me
talk about this before because i thought
they could have gone in this direction
in the show
but since almost all of the evidence is
in the books
i guess i can understand why they did it
another way
in the books i believe melisandre will
be instrumental in the defeat of the
white walkers
i believe melisandre will have to
sacrifice herself to the fire
in order to stop them from taking over
everything
now let me explain as i was saying
before
i did make a video about this almost
three years ago
and i can't believe it's already been
that long but if you saw that video
then you would know i said this theory
had a better chance of happening in the
books
than it did in the show now one thing
that was never mentioned in the show was
azor ahai
the legendary hero who had a burning
sword known as lightbringer
in the books this hero is mentioned over
and over again
whenever we see melisandre talk about
this in the books almost everything she
says is either happening right now
or about to happen in the winds of
winter melisandre says
in the ancient books of asshai it is
written that there will come a day
after a long summer when the stars bleed
and the cold breath of darkness falls
heavy on the world
in this dread hour a warrior shall draw
from the fire a burning sword and that
sword shall be lightbringer
the red sword of heroes and whoever it
is that holds this sword
shall be azor ahai come again so let's
break down what melisandre said
she said there will come a day after a
long summer when the stars bleed
and the cold breath of darkness falls
heavy on the world
this has actually already happened
westeros is now
entering their winter after a very long
summer
this will also be when the stars bleed
and darkness falls heavy over everything
well we have already seen the stars
bleed when we saw the red comet in the
sky
and now the darkness is about to fall
heavy over westeros
once the white walkers bring the long
night when they invade
all of this is happening right now then
melisandre says when this does happen
there will be a warrior who will draw
from the fire or burning sword
and that sword shall be lightbringer the
red sword of heroes
at first melisandre thinks this will be
stannis but in the very last book
we find out melisandre sees something
different now that we are getting so
close to the battle against the white
walkers i believe melisandre will find
out the right answers because we are
obviously running out of time
we were given all this misdirection in
the earlier books but now that we are on
the brink of the battle
we find out who melisandre should be
focusing on
when she finally has her own chapter in
the last book melisandre looks into the
flames for answers but she does not see
stannis
what it said was yet now she could not
even seem to find her king
i pray for a glimpse of azor ahai and
where lore shows me only snow
now if you noticed the word snow has a
capital s
this is referring to someone's name when
melisandre looks into the fire for azor
ahai
all she can see is jon snow now i
realize this might be obvious to some of
you
a lot of the fans already believe jon
snow is azor ahai
that's not actually why i'm making the
video i'm making this video because
melisandre has yet to realize the
sacrifice she will need to make in order
for azor ahai to be reborn
as i said before melisandre will be
instrumental in all of this for a number
of different reasons
as of right now in the books jon snow is
dead
or i should say we last saw him as he
was bleeding out
into the snow melisandre says something
very interesting to john
right before he is stabbed she said when
the red star bleeds and darkness gathers
azor ahai shall be born again melisandre
will be the reason jon snow is reborn
after she helps bring him back it will
be very different than the way we saw it
done in the show
but she will bring him back in some
shape or form nonetheless
jon has even had a dream about this
right before he was stabbed
in this dream jon can see himself
standing on top of the wall
he is armored in black ice but his blade
burned red
in his fist why do you think george
brought melisandre to jon snow
these characters are meant for something
much bigger but they need each other
jon will need melisandre to bring him
back but melisandre will need jon to
become azor ahai
melisandre has already made so many
sacrifices over the years
she has sacrificed so many to the flames
but her final sacrifice will be her
greatest
that's when she will have to give up her
own life for the greater good of the
realm
stannis actually said it best when he
dropped some knowledge on jon snow
this is also when we get another azor
ahai reference interestingly enough
when stannis and john are speaking
together at castle black
stannis said you may lack your father's
honor
or your brother's skill in arms but you
are the weapon the lord has given me
even azor ahai did not win his war alone
now this almost sounds like something
melisandre would say to jon
when she finally realizes stannis is not
azor ahai
like stannis said here john is the
weapon the lord has given me
jon is the weapon the lord of light has
given melisandre
but like azor ahai even john needs help
think about it there are no other
characters more focused or determined to
stop being the darkness from gathering
over westeros then melisandre
and jon snow melisandre sings about this
darkness
and the hero who will stop it over and
over again you think the lord of light
is worried about who sits on the iron
throne
melisandre's one and only focus is to
stop the great other
then you have jon snow who immediately
joins the night's watch
the brotherhood that guards the wall
from the darkness that lies beyond
this is their destiny now this is where
game of thrones made one of its biggest
mistakes
the writers should have never deviated
from what george rr martin was setting
up from the very beginning
just because jon snow seems like the
obvious choice now that the whole
internet is talking about it
doesn't mean you have to go back and
change everything this was already set
in motion in the very first book
i said well what do i do with that what
do i do with that
yeah these people have guessed the
secret that i'm gonna reveal in book six
people have already guessed that here
and book two is just out
you really have two choices there you
can ignore it and proceed with your plan
despite the fact that some people know
where you're going
or you can get all panicky and say oh my
god they've figured it out i can't let
that be i'll have to change it i'll have
to go in a different direction
and i i think some writers do that and i
think that's always a mistake
yeah you know if you've planned your
book that the butler did it
and then you read an internet someone
has figured out that the butler did it
and you suddenly change in mid-stream
and it was the chambermaid who did it
then you screw up the whole book because
you get these this foreshadowing
early on and you've got these little
clues you planted now they're dead ends
and
you have to introduce other clues and
your retconning
you have to follow through with all the
foreshadowing that was already there
otherwise you can ruin your story now
you have to think about what azor ahai
had to do
in order to make his red sword of heroes
lightbringer he had to forge his blade
in the sacred fires
we find out how this was done in one of
davis's chapters
when it says a hundred days and a
hundred nights he labored on the third
blade
and as it glowed white hot in the sacred
fires he summoned his wife
nissanissa he said to her for that was
her name
bury your breast and know that i love
you best of all that is in this world
she did this thing why i cannot say an
azor ahai thrust the smoking sword
through her living heart
it is said that her cry of anguish and
ecstasy left a crack across the face of
the moon
so as you can see the only way his blade
would catch on fire was by shoving it
into the heart of a woman
like a blacksmith he has to forge his
blade inside of a fiery heart
a flaming heart is exactly what
melisandre has as her sigil
this is the symbol that she represents
stannis even has it sewn onto his
banners
over and over again we are told
melisandre not only has a connection to
the fire
but she is basically the physical
embodiment of fire
john even reminds himself of this in the
last book in john's chapter
he thinks to himself ygritte was only
kissed by fire
but melisandre was fire and her hair was
blood and flame
now i need you to remember exactly what
it said in the prophecy about azor ahai
thrusting his sword into nissanese's
heart
it said azor ahai thrusts the smoking
sword through her living heart
i want you to focus on what it said at
the end it doesn't just say heart
but it says living heart now let me show
you what it says in another one of
davos's chapters when he thinks about
killing melisandre himself
this is right after the battle of
blackwater bay not only did stannis and
davos lose that battle
but davos also lost several of his sons
in the battle
he now has even more reasons to want
melisandre dead
so shortly after he's rescued from the
rock
davos thinks i will cut the living heart
from her breast
and see how it burns when someone thinks
about killing melisandre
we get several references that match up
with the azor ahai prophecy
it says living heart her breast and
seeing how it will burn
this is exactly how melisandre will die
when she is sacrificed
in the winds of winter jon will shove
his sword through her breast
into her living heart which will cause
the sword to burn and then glow red
making it lightbringer the red sword of
heroes if that's not foreshadowing then
i guess i don't know what is
now imagine what it must have smelled
like when azor ahai stuck his sword
into nissanissa it would have smelled
like blood
and iron and smoke and fire as the sword
burned
it would have smelled exactly like a
forge very similar to the one we saw
gendry working in
this would have a very distinct smell
now what do you think melisandre might
smell like
well we actually find this out when
someone notices her scent as they are
standing very close to each other
this is what jon notices as they are
riding to the top of the wall together
in the close confines of the iron cage
he was acutely aware of the red woman's
presence
she even smells red the scent reminded
him of miken's forge
of the way iron smelled when red hot
descent was smoking blood
kissed by fire he thought once again if
that's not foreshadowing then i guess i
don't know what is
jon notices melisandre smells like
mike's forge
the same way iron smells when it's red
hot descent is of smoke and blood
this is exactly what azor ahai would
have smelled when he shoved his sword
into nissa nissa
now if this isn't fascinating enough let
me show you what melisandre says
right after john notices her scent
because this is very interesting as well
as they're still riding to the top of
the wall john says
you are not cold my lady melisandre
laughed
never the ruby at her throat seemed to
pulse
in time with the beating of her heart
the lord's fire lives within me jon snow
feel she laid her hand on his cheek and
held it there while he felt how warm she
was
alright so as you can see here we get
another reference of melisandre having a
fire burning inside of her
i don't think it's a coincidence we find
this out in jon snow's chapter
while they're together jon snow is aware
of azor ahai in nissanissa so he knows
what has to be done to forge
lightbringer
now he's seeing all these signs that
indicate melisandre maybe nissanissa
remember john has already seen himself
in a dream standing atop the wall
fighting the dead while holding a
burning red sword
in his hand now i also need you to
remember what it said right here about
melisandre
it says she is always warm even when
she's at the wall because the lord's
fire lives within her
this right here can also be said for
nissanissa we find this out when mr
raymond
leaves a very interesting book behind
for jon to read
there is something inside this book that
maester aemon wants john to see
this is what jon says i looked at that
book mr amen left me
the jade compendium the pages that told
of azor ahai
lightbringer was never cold to the touch
but warm as nissanissa had been warm
now doesn't it sound like nissanissa and
melisandre share
the same characteristic they are always
warm to the touch
because they both have the lord's fire
within them maester aemon left john this
book so he would realize stannis is not
azor ahai
because stannis sword was never warm to
the touch melisandre will realize
jon snow is the one after she brings him
back from the dead
she has already seen snow when she looks
into the flames but she still believes
it's stannis because she's already
invested so much in him
but as soon as something miraculous
happens like a resurrection
melisandre will finally set her sights
on jon snow
the song of ice and fire melisandre has
already made so many sacrifices to the
fire
her whole purpose for living is to fight
the great other
and save the entire realm from an
endless night in the end
she will have to make one final
sacrifice only death can pay for life
in a great gift like azor ahai and
lightbringer
requires a great sacrifice george r.r
martin will not betray his own
foreshadowing like
dan and dave did with the show the show
is the show and the books are the books
dave and dan are doing a great job and
they're doing a very faithful thing but
they're
they're operating under constraints that
i don't have
and budget
running time uh you know the
practicalities of production
um so there are places where the two are
going to diverge
and they are going to diverge i'm not
gonna
i'm not gonna once again go back and
make the chambermaid do it said
the butler did it because because of
something david and dan and did in the
show
jon snow will not sit on the sidelines
during the great war for the dawn
now as of right now there isn't a night
king in the books
there are white walkers and whites of
course but we have yet to see someone
like a night king who leads all of the
dead
so if this does happen and jon snow
forges lightbringer
i don't think that necessarily means we
will see him fight at night king one
versus one
john will more than likely just be the
one who leads the fight
he will have to bring everyone together
sort of like he did in the show
the only difference is he will make a
much bigger impact in the final battle
against the dead
even if that means giving his own life
again
we saw a lot of our favorite characters
survive the long night battle in the
show
this will not happen in the winds of
winter many sacrifices will have to be
made
many of our favorite characters will
have to die in order to stop the white
walkers from taking over the seven
kingdoms
now there is another video that i want
to make next about the lord of light
i have a crazy idea about how or maybe
even why melisandre is able to see
things in the fire
it's something i only started to think
about recently so it's not a fully
fleshed out theory video
but it's something i want to discuss
nonetheless but let me know what you
thought about this one down below
as always thanks for watching also i
want to give a big shout out to everyone
supporting the channel on patreon
i hope all of you have a great day i
will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you